it reinvented Howie Mandel's career
reinvented didn't it invent no no I
like how he's I like how we like how I
wonder I did Howie's podcast yeah and he
said do you think you could call anyone
a [__] and I said ah yeah pretty much
it's me thing yeah and he's like can you
ring up my wife and call her a [__] and
then like when someone puts it in front
of you like that yeah oh God can I yeah
and so I rang up and he goes uh he Rings
his wife up and he goes Jim Jefferies
once uh he goes someone here wants to
speak to you I'll tell you who I am I
said hey how you doing you [__] and she
goes oh I love you
yeah what do you mean what do you mean
Connie's [__]
what do you think a [__] is yeah because
I've seen uh
called women cons is that what this is
the thing is the problem with America is
the word Khan is wrapped up in calling a
woman a [__] where in the rest of the
world the word can't I'd be more likely
to call you a cuntland to call you a
[__] I I've I've called very few women
in my life are coming I've got all my
mates I call [__] and call me a [__]
what you're saying no no no no no no
it's just like you could be in Ireland a
term investment you go oh my maid over
he's a good [__] right oh I would argue
the word [__] is
actually softer than the word [__] I
think so too yeah but I think well
please tell me a lot more well because I
could go I could go Oh that girl over
there I go I'm my wife she's a bloody
[__] she is [__] hell she's a [__] if
I said that right yeah but if I went why
she's a [__] she is [__] ill she's a
[__] yeah but something you're right
nasty and me you're right maybe but I
would argue that it can't it sounds
softer from you because I understand how
it's how it is in Australia but if I
were to hear George Kimmel it's the
accent where I hear Americans say it I
just go what are you doing I meant to
say that let me try it let me try it so
yeah this is my pal here he's a [__]
[__] too much
my friend George he's a [__] softly easy
oh yeah this is my friend George he's a
good [__] yeah yeah he's better yeah
he's a bit it's and then you start using
words oh that's a bit [__] uh you know
what George's doing is a little content
can you use it sexually like let me eat
your [__] ah I don't
yeah why not I just use it in every
other part of my life I know but you
wanted me
all right
would you if a guy was you met a guy on
Raya yeah right okay like that guy that
you matched with that's my friend I
didn't match with him the one that liked
you right this piece of [__] right right
she's allowed to die here she wants now
let's get to that let's ask that because
that's that for a second okay thanks Jim
all right
that's not sad so let me just found out
all right guys so I understand that but
okay so you're married right yeah I am
right you get a divorce I met my wife
did you really yeah all right
a month later yeah you guys break up and
it's six months okay six months later
yeah a year yeah you find out that I
liked your wife knowing that that was
your wife how do you how would you feel
about it
I wouldn't be happy only because I
wouldn't want you near my kids
it's the constant nudity Bobby
[Laughter]
all right
I don't like that yeah I don't like that
you're one of the guys I would
encouraged
why because you don't think I'll be as
good or what I've heard your distance is
terrible and they like
yeah yeah my distance is bad yeah yeah
so um if this guy was eating you out and
he was like let me eat your [__] how
would you feel about it I not good okay
not great so in sexual you know and I
don't want to put myself but if I did it
would it be more acceptable because the
accent said yes yeah how would you say
it I'm gonna you can
wow
that was so good dude holy [__] I can't
say the word that's why I never use it
it's just I have to think about it it's
so natural with him you know what I mean
yeah that's amazing I
British people did on stage but now it's
like in Australia I remember in the
comedy
comedy now it's like the whole